theorist as wonderful to meet you thank
you for your help and support to
refugees the worker well I tried does is
admirable in inspiring good luck with
the amazing efforts and work best wishes
go Ali I'm Jasso Hara and I'm the
founder of the worldwide tribe probably
loud would be the first one and
passionate and creative so the well I
tried is an organization and a kind of
fun line community that supports
refugees across the world but we focus
on communication so we install Wi-Fi
into refugee camps and we also tell
stories and raise awareness when it
comes to changing something in history
yeah I don't know I do you have that
releases like everything kind of
happened exactly as it should and
there's lots of things that you can't
have you can't impact how they happen
what happened but you can impact how you
react to it my role model at the moment
is my little brother Mesirow
because he is my inspiration for
everything I do
he's fostered he come from Eritrea he
left his country when he was 13 to see
compulsory military service and he made
the craziest journey across the Sahara
Desert and Kostyra concert everything
was a I think if I ever think wow this
is a challenge where this is hard I just
think about that journey that he did and
he could do that room I can do it not
following what I believe in and being
true for myself I'm not listening to
that instinct in that in a guide I think
that being as close to that as possible
is when you feel the best and happiest
and I really see that that in my work
now a lot of people might think that I'm
crazy if you have quit my job and really
throwing my everything into this work
but I really listened to myself and what
I felt like I should be doing I needed
to be doing
two years later and it's still going so
I think there's something to be said for
that
hopefully on a beach somewhere and
somewhere warmer than London I think
definitely but yeah I really believe
that I'll still be doing this work I
don't think that the refugee crisis is
going anywhere I think that you know as
environmental factors come into play
there will be more people displaced in
the world and that if I can continue to
push this narrative of we are all on
this tile together regardless of Judah's
nationalities religions and languages
you know we will share this world
together and then that's that narrative
that I was still pushing twenty years
down the line I think that everybody has
their own something to give in our
lifetime in this world and the key is to
find what that is you know not everybody
needs to be putting up tents in the
jungle in Calais or pulling people off
both on the shores of lesbos and
everybody has the primal capacity to do
that or the money to give but everybody
has something to give and me I think
that it has been about sharing through
writing and visually on social media
some of the stories of the people that
I've met and bringing a kind of voice to
some of some of the people that don't
have a voice are being hired within this
crisis and that kind of communication
and bringing together over communities
that's what I think where my skills have
been best placed within this crazy
crisis
we're all the same we're all human we
will share this world together we will
have a responsibility for one another
and you know if you're if any if any of
humanity is suffering or in pain and we
that has a negative impact on your back
we're definitely connected
thank you very much listening to my
story to subscribe click the button here
to watch more content from Drammen UK